[Music]
they say never meet your idol face to
face and
your idol face to face who's your Idol
no I mean you need me oh I'm you're in
my eyes
you just told me I look uglier I'm
annoying yeah and you're like where are
we going you know it's a tough space
conversation is boring oh wow okay
yeah
[Music]
hello hello I'm not really much of a
handshaker I'm more of a hugger oh yeah
oh yes
oh nice oh oh wait I got your hair I got
a shower I got your hair you got gray
hair so thank you very much my bracelet
caught it you like it I do like your
hair have you ever been of a white guy
we have a similar texture have you ever
been a white guy before are you fully
white though
I mean my skin color is white like so in
the UK I feel like if you're a lighter
skin or have a certain hair texture they
consider you white right I mean to me
white is a color we have this thing like
where you're like oh you're not white
you're English but I'm white essentially
my skin colors wet okay but what is your
do I like white guys have you ever been
for white guy before
yes I yeah what's your ethnic groups I'm
black
I'm I'm just like see in the U.S I think
we view it differently like even if you
like have you know your lighter skin or
have mixed Heritage down the line you
still will consider yourself like the
black race like you if someone asks me I
say I'm black I'm not mixed I'm not
biracial I'm not white but it's
different here right listen it doesn't
Define you as a person
what defines you as a person he just
skipped over that complaint what's your
heritage though like what's your mixture
I'm English what's your mixture your
your your appearance I'm English
race I'm English English is not a race
it's a nationality you know that right
so I'm white you're white both of your
parents are white correct really yes
oh so you know John B is
no but I don't want to know about John B
I don't even know about you you know I
mean I've got this beautiful lady
sitting in front of me and I'm I'm
hearing about John B American women know
who I'm talking about tell me something
interesting about you instead about me
something interesting not something like
looking for an average answer but I
don't know what you would find
interesting I got to know more about you
because I'm sure I would find you
interesting something that I think is
interesting you may say and that's
boring and that's that's the beauty of
people you have different interests and
what's interesting about me what's
interesting
um I used to work at Vogue I'm looking
at Tom Ford here in the Vogue thing I
used to work at Vogue magazine that's
all right so what are your passions is
that interesting to you listen I'm sure
if I got to know you a bit more I find a
lot very interesting everyone's got a
lot of but I mean that is a lot of
texture to them do you know are you
interested in me working at both I'd
love to ask you so much more about it
we've got a limited time so okay but
don't speed through it let's just let it
flow naturally don't worry about the
time I'm all good don't worry do you
find me attractive by the way
I do find you attractive how old are you
[Laughter]
um
I feel like you have to think about it I
feel like it's not the time
I feel like it's not the time to stop
putting numbers and labels on things do
you know what I mean you don't even know
my name yet
oh my gosh I don't it's terrible isn't
it like I skipped right past that I'll
introduce myself I'm Diego Diego
how old are you
as I said I don't think it's that time
to but not I'm 21. you're 21. oh she
gave me the sympathy one no no no like
I'm actually surprised I thought you
were older like I don't know what I mean
because you seem more mature if I'm
honest so like yeah it is a compliment
I'm shocked you're really confident she
knows it's the way you portray yourself
you're really 21. yeah
looks so gorgeous 1981 never yeah wait
what year were you born I can't do math
oh no I'm slow I just wanted I'm born in
the 21st century so I'm leaving it's
like 2 000. we're centuries apart wait
wait did you during the year I graduated
or after I graduated high school
no I don't have a problem with it hey it
is what it is I just find it fast I
think it's interesting I was born in
2001. dear God I graduated high school
in 1999. um
so far apart yet so close together
I'm my lion this may be the most
interesting part about you is your age
right now so far what because I
portrayed whoa my the most interesting
part of me is my age so because I I mean
I what I do I don't know if you know
what I do for a living so I talk to Men
of all ages I usually talk to men and so
I've talked to very young guys and so
I'd usually judge a man older younger
based on who he is and not just
basically that is a huge age Gap yeah
have you ever dated a woman
20 years older than you I've never been
in a relationship personally but I've uh
I would say I'm
used to I slept with somebody slept with
the older one yeah you've got some
cougars that chase you down yeah don't
chase me they don't chase you no we We
Vibe what's the oldest woman you've been
with
this is information that is not being
leaked on okay I forgot order online
do you know it's all about the like
level of connection and obviously when
I'm talking to to older women I feel
like I can level a bit more on it
because I've done the little kiddy
things in my life you understand I've
I've got that out of the way we all have
a little time in our life that we have
to get out of our system and I've got
that out of my system you have not
at 21 got anything else it's 21
shouldn't have anything else a man who's
traveled over half of the world worked
actually
I shouldn't tell you what you should and
shouldn't have no it's all right you
know I can show you it's all right like
we all judge everyone right we all have
connotations with certain things and by
being a young man I'd expect to have
have connotations but I'm actually in
shock right now I'm in shock about how
beautiful you are for what thank you 41.
I don't believe I'm leaving are you
trying to say that older women are ugly
no but with age women lose they lose
they lose their they lose their shine
well listen that's where the love comes
in right when you're in love with
someone like they just look beautiful to
whatever so I'm after I make you fall in
love with me and then and then you have
to think about our numbers this is so
funny to me this is hilarious okay so
all right so you're born born and raised
here like where have you traveled you
talked about you've traveled all over
everyone how did you like you just
traveled on your own for work for a
hobby since being young I've worked a
lot covered money and and grown grown my
business to the stage Rock and work what
do you do well you mentioned work I
normally don't go into all that but you
mentioned you said because of that yeah
I don't like to talk about too much but
what I do essentially I am uh or what
your passion is I fly a lot of girls on
the street for a living
are you a YouTuber
what do we even call ourselves now
influences oh so you're influencers so
you go up and meet women you do like the
interviews yeah flirt with them mine's a
bit more natural like a bit of a
conversation and just getting to know
girls how come you what are you why do
you interview girls
when I started doing the whole content
creation thing I looked at my kind of CV
and was like what am I good at and one
thing I was always good at was was being
talking to girls being a flirt but you
know it all comes down to it all comes
down to self-confidence
ah if you don't look good you can have
all the confidence in the world girls
are not going to fill you you know that
right that's not true
that's not true
that's not true and we'll talk about it
more on our second date oh really okay
it's all these Nigerian
um people like selling like having
different stands selling stuff and
they're just like trying to sell me
different things it's like I was like am
I in Italy or am I in like Africa so
like Lagos not Nest I'm just looking for
peace man you looking for peace I'm not
trying to be out can she weigh 500
pounds and she gives you peace
you said Peace